there's a guy okay forget his name but
most people on a Google search could
find it but we're talking about Anthony
here so maybe he won't be able to find
it but there's a guy who has decided
years ago that he was an alien that's
like how he felt in the world how he
identified he wanted this to his
appearance to match that as well look up
black Al he he calls himself a black
alien not like black african- americ is
he black no he's he's I don't even think
he's American he's just like this man
turns himself into black alien by
removing nose and his top lip yo what up
homie G what's his name what's his name
that's a real person God he was nice
looking
Anthony so bad for his nose his oh he's
he's an Italian [__] guy from America
dude that's so bad for his nose bro he
took his nose off what do you mean it's
bad for his nose he has no more nose
that's not
healthy yeah he made his eyes black dude
what up play out let's get lit honestly
honestly [__] this guy dude okay well
he's [__] absolutely scaring the [__]
out of people wherever he goes in the
world he has the [__] balls the
[__] audacity the [__] todr to
complain that he can't get hired places
he does yeah dude he's like I get
discriminated against nobody will hire
me no [__] [__] you made yourself on
purpose look like a [__] alien which
isn't a thing because no one looks knows
what aliens look like because nobody
knows that aliens [__] exist so you
can't say you look like a [__] alien
cuz aliens aren't a thing dude imagine
his head imagine what are the bumps in
his head like what is that [__] I mean
who the [__] knows man you what I mean
he's the [__] alien he wanted bumps
on his head because that's how he there
just bumps on his head you know it's
just [__] he put plastic under his
Anthony dude if somebody pulled a gun on
Anthony he would just be like wait who
are you wait wait wait what color is the
handle of that gun yeah yeah yeah hold
on hold on a second who who whoa whoa
where'd you get those pants yeah um so
all
right yeah his last words were where you
get those pants um the imagine you
checking out at [__] that's what I
mean Barrel like how could this guy's
got [__] some sack on him You' got
the black Al complaining what up homie
G where did you find this it doesn't
have a code on it so
dumb hey F where did you find this I
need to go get a something so I could
scan it oh thank you for chisel why do
he sound like a robot because he's an
alien dude thanks so much homie it's so
weird that was lit that that people
think that was so [__] lit aliens as
looking a certain way that's so [__]
stupid actually like the little green
men thing and also this [__] [__]
[__] piece of [__] [__] you know so
Italian hey Anthony lafredo now you're a
[__] alien hey what the [__] come
over here and suck my [__] crank hey
player I have some [__] marinara on
my crank have you heard the new Lucas
join her it's so
hot what is Lucas boy does he have his
ear to the streets anyway why are you
yelling dude do you I need to scan this
ceramic you're yelling so loud but I
don't have a code where did you find
this why is he always looking for a
[__] code
cuz that's for cron Barrel dude oh these
wicker chairs
they wow oh these cushions don't have a
tag on it oh my God for shizel can you
please help wow let me call mananagement
so dumb dude but wait he looks even more
different now scroll down
further he looks like way more [__] up
than even that but there we go oh God
you pissed me off more than anyone in
the history of the [__] universe way
to go man you're the most [__]
terrible looking [__] human being of
all time by the way he just like and you
did it on purpose he just look like a
lizard he looks like a reptile dude
you're not an alien you're a [__]
reptile look at his shitty tank top that
looks like it's on his body because it
just is black does he smudge [__] like
no dude no oh look at the [__] thing
it says under the picture Anthony
lafredo said he now dreams of removing
his skin and replacing it with
metal that ought to work so tired he'll
be so tired all the time so heavy that
is so
so hello
homie bye thank you for coming to cron
bizar what's the name of that what's the
name of
that dude look at his eyebrows I hate
when people don't put their cards back
[__] God damn it I'm going to do a
187 on
them bro you're going to sleep like a
baby
tonight you
know all right
well God damn that is terrible look at
that one just says regret question mark
[__] God damn it I was gonna say
something now [__] these customers are
loed out godamn
it jeez dude oh it's bad what's the name
of that [__] Japanese movie where he
turns into Paras this metal guy it's an
awesome movie actually I don't know but
it's definitely about revenge because
it's a Japanese movie no it is there's
never been a Japanese movie not about
revenge [__] this guy man [__] this
[__] [__] you know got let it it's
just
[__] it's just [__] [__]
gorgeous [__] I was thinking about a
[__] other person who got something
different with their body oh well that's
so vague and I can't remember now
because we spent too much time on Tony
Le lalia [__] his name Tony lefo the
black alien the self professed black
alien dude why he's not even black he's
gray where is
he you want like where he where New
Jersey he's oh he's definitely from New
Jersey yeah he is you saw his face from
before all this you know he's from New
Jersey yeah yeah you know what I mean
not for nothing but where we going
tonight that was what he used to be like
and now he's still like that still like
that but he looks like a [__] hey not
for nothing but we get in a bottle
somewhere he looks a lizard yeah ah man
you know what let's go to Whole Nine
let's get the [__] good stuff go grab
it from France oh he's he's French oh
wow what do you who who you got what hey
you raw dogger did you raw dog
her hey let me ask you a question man
did you raw dog her or what just an
alien in your
face have some of this man this is
[__] crazy this [__] go to Whole Nine
drink the whole thing come on you raw
dog her
you done with her or what I'm I'm GNA go
talk to her you done with her this guy
[__] oh look at his hand this guy makes
me [__] arm he cut off two of his
fingers on each hand you're kidding me
no oh this guy's de wait well why didn't
you say that already because there's so
much to say I forgot you done with her
I'm going to I'm going to finger her
guess which two fingers I'm going to use
nah not for nothing but these two you're
done with her stop saying you're done
with her what hey honey hey honey like
this he's like this like this he's like
this she's like oh my God he's like oh
yeah you're about to go to Whole Nine
here we go oh you oh oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah and she comes he says ah [__]
I'm done with
her you need to relax
dude look at him look at his arms dude
he cut off his fingers bro yep yep yep
because as you know aliens only have
three fingers on each
hand at the beach at the beach what a
[__] dumb [__] what if he was like
implants installed under his skin on his
head and arms bro work out if you want
bigger arms you [__] free dude could
you imagine look at the metal in his
head look at the metal in his head I
hate him oh god I've never hated someone
that I don't know more than this guy but
you got to chill out about that it's
just making me so mad though look at
what sweet little boy he was I get it
okay he's had a lot of
trauma you know he cut off his fingers
dude this is crazy to me
because there's so much less you can do
now I know it's nuts I mean it's just
he's not going to be happy when he's 60
if he's he's not happy now dude I mean
well of course he's gonna be dead soon
because of the metal he put in his head
on
purpose H how does he lift weights and
get he's that strong with no he doesn't
did he really cut off his fingers yes
Chris yes he also has metal in his arms
so who knows if those are H doc not for
nothing but take these two
off you got to wonder how he even got
them off no nobody would perform that
medical procedure that's mutilation he
went to tur turkey you know oh yeah for
sure [__] yeah he did turkey will do
anything for 20 grand wow you know
that's such a [__] go anywhere boner
for hating on it's all good it's
just all right well all right well
enough of that something better
something better something better he's
got to [__] drinking wine
like aliens get drunk off wine you know
yeah dude look you could see it clear
with his fingers there yeah I know and
look at his face he he scarred and up I
mean what a terrible human being oh dude
I'm this is we shouldn't started talking
about this this is what a terrible human
being all right change it get it
out what do you want to talk about
instead anything man not not that dude I
had something to say and then you wow
that's so bad the only thing Anthony was
good at Googling and it was that I know
it happened to be that yeah so [__]
annoying he's like got it right here yep
just vomit City yeah vomit City for sure
I think he just Googled not for nothing
and that came up